Générique
...
-Bonjour, bienvenue dans
"Politiques, à table !" sur LCP.
On se retrouve autour d'un plat,
d'un dessert, d'un invité.
Cette semaine, nous recevons
Pascal Lavergne,
bonjour.
-Bonjour.
-Avec moi, pour présenter,
Jean-Pierre Montanay.
-Bonjour, Brigitte,
bonjour, M. Lavergne.
-Bonjour.
-Vous êtes député
Renaissance de Gironde depuis 2018.
Engagé politiquement à gauche,
vous quittez le PS
pour La République en Marche
en 2017 pour suivre Emmanuel Macron.
Ingénieur agronome
de profession, vous avez
longtemps cultivé une double vie.
Vous aimez les blondes,
les blondes d'Aquitaine,
au point d'en compter
une trentaine
dans votre exploitation
de Saint-Sulpice-de-Guilleragues,
aujourd'hui
en fermage. Vous avez aussi
exploité de la vigne, toujours
dans le Bordelais,
et été restaurateur.
De la fourche à la fourchette,
vous êtes le témoin exigeant
de nos assiettes
et au menu, justement,
une bonne viande, un bon vin.
-Exactement. Du lourd.
Un faux-filet
sauce bordelaise, donc au vin,
et en dessert,
une tarte au citron,
mais sans meringue.
-Dans Le dessous
des plats, on se rapprochera
de la terre avec le Wwoofing,
une tendance qui fleurit
un peu partout dans le monde.
-Dans Les pieds
dans le plat, le glyphosate, c'est
reparti pour 10 ans en Europe.
Faut-il s'en inquiéter ?
-Allez, on passe à table,
tout de suite,
Cuisine et confidences.
-Pascal Lavergne,
je dis d'abord
chapeau ! Oser le faux-filet
à la bordelaise ici
est un acte de bravoure culinaire
de nos jours
dans ce climat de diabolisation
de la viande rouge,
où même certains carnassiers,
Brigitte en a été témoin, d'hier
se dégonflent aujourd'hui
en arrivant
ici avouant leur conversion récente
pour le quinoa, histoire de ne pas
être charcutés
sur le billot des réseaux.
Le faux-filet, l'entrecôte
sont des gros mots,
pour ceux qui veulent
éradiquer la viande
de nos assiettes
et saper les élevages, c'est-à-dire
votre métier, vous qui engraissiez
une centaine de boeufs avec amour
et passion, vous qui passiez
du fumier mouillé
aux parquets de l'Assemblée.
On comprend pourquoi vous,
le député paysan, vous incarnez
cette résistance avec ce faux-filet.
Vous êtes engagé volontaire
dans ce bataillon
des cocardiers défenseurs
des terroirs. Un bon vin, une bonne
viande, un bon fromage, ce n'est
pas du Macron dans le texte,
mais c'est du Roussel
et ça pourrait être
votre devise.
-Pourquoi pas ?
Je n'ai pas du tout hésité
quand il s'est agi
de choisir un plat pour venir
le déguster en votre présence.
J'assume parfaitement le fait
d'avoir été éleveur,
d'avoir un pied encore
sur une exploitation que j'ai
mise en fermage
il y a très peu de temps,
je défends l'agriculture française,
je suis le défenseur
d'une façon d'élever des animaux
et je veux réaffirmer ici
au travers de ce plat choisi
de viande rouge
que l'élevage bovin,
l'élevage en France,
apporte beaucoup
d'externalités positives
à la biodiversité quand on élève
les animaux
sur des terroirs de prairies.
Pensons à toutes ces zones
du Massif central,
à l'Allier, au Charolais,
qui élèvent des animaux
sur des prairies, voilà,
qui apportent beaucoup
de qualité à nos paysages,
ces paysages encore bocagers.
-C'est
politiquement incorrect
de manger de la viande.
-Je m'en fiche
du politiquement correct.
Vous savez, j'ai été
jeudi dernier à un congrès
sur l'agroécologie à Bordeaux.
Il devait
y avoir à peu près
400 ou 450 personnes
dans la salle. Je n'avais jamais
vu autant d'écolos en même temps
réunis autour de l'intervenant
et un député Renaissance présent.
A un moment,
un des intervenants a dit,
il faut manger moins de viande.
Certes, oui.
-Vous êtes d'accord.
Les études disent
qu'il faut manger moins de viande
rouge notamment.
-Oui,
parce que pour la santé,
c'est une bonne chose,
pour l'équilibre planétaire aussi,
pour nourrir toutes les populations
sur tous les continents,
avoir un peu moins
de consommation d'une viande
qui utilise des céréales
qui pourraient être
directement consommées
par les humains directement.
Je le conçois.
-Vous êtes
contre l'élevage intensif ?
-On y reviendra.
Mais en l'occurrence,
la viande produite
en France, si pour l'engraisser,
il faut des céréales,
on a aussi des élevages qui sont
naisseurs, qui sont éleveurs
et ça se fait sur des prairies.
Les prairies,
on abordera ce sujet du glyphosate,
on n'utilise pas
de glyphosate sur les prairies,
et les prairies apportent
des externalités positives
pour conserver l'eau dans le sol,
pour augmenter les taux de matière
organique des sols
et c'est important
pour l'agriculture française.
-Vous trouvez qu'on accompagne bien
les agriculteurs, les éleveurs,
en disant, il faut manger
moins de viande, mais vous aviez
vos blondes d'Aquitaine,
un cheptel d'une trentaine
à peu près
de vaches, de boeufs, vous avez
l'impression qu'on accompagne
aujourd'hui suffisamment ?
-Il y a un discours ambiant délétère
pour les agriculteurs.
Chaque fois qu'on voit, comme ça a
été le cas il y a quelques mois,
repris par la presse,
sans doute de façon maladroite,
le rapport qui avait été fait
par la Cour des comptes,
j'ai fait des bonds de 1 km
de haut, c'est pas possible.
Quand vous êtes
agriculteur,
que vous lisez ce qu'on a lu,
de ce qu'il avait été
ressorti de ce rapport,
comment les agriculteurs pouvaient
le lire ? Les gars, vous polluez.
Ce que vous faites,
ce que vous produisez,
il faut pas en manger, parce que
c'est pas bon pour la santé,
c'est pas bon pour l'environnement,
et donc on leur dit, vous servez
à rien et vous allez disparaître.
Sincèrement, quand vous avez
fait de ce métier
votre vie tout entière,
que vous avez mis tout votre coeur,
parce qu'on fait pas ce métier
sans y être charnellement attaché,
à nos animaux,
à notre terroir. On fait
ce métier par passion.
Quand vous lisez ça,
ça vous fend le coeur.
Vous avez envie
de prendre une corde et vous pendre.
-Vous avez 2 casquettes,
la politique menée,
selon vous, elle va dans le sens
des éleveurs ?
-Moi, je crois qu'en tout cas,
à la place qui est la mienne,
je fais passer des messages
dans la majorité, mais également
en direction de l'opposition,
pour dire
combien l'élevage est important,
comme je viens de le dire ici,
et s'il y a un combat que
je mènerai jusqu'au dernier jour,
ça sera celui-ci. Je ne suis pas
fils d'agriculteur, j'ai choisi
ce métier depuis l'âge de 7 ans.
Il se trouve que je suis passé
par plusieurs étapes avant,
mais je l'assume jusqu'au bout
et jusqu'à mon dernier souffle,
je défendrai l'agriculture
et l'élevage français.
Sachant que j'ai conscience
de tout cet environnement négatif,
mais la nécessité de dire combien
les agriculteurs ont fait d'efforts
depuis des décennies,
que moi, je les observe,
plus de 40 ans de ma vie.
L'agriculture, elle se rénove
au rythme des saisons,
au rythme du climat.
-On entend bien votre combat.
-Sincèrement,
il faut laisser le temps
à l'agriculture.
-La viande rouge est dans
votre assiette. On va la goûter.
Dites-nous pourquoi vous avez
choisi ce plat. C'est un plat
symbolique des vendanges
dans le Bordelais ?
-J'ai choisi
ce plat pour 2 raisons.
Un, c'est de la viande rouge
et je veux la réhabiliter.
Vous l'avez compris.
-Le message est passé.
-Que j'ai été
éleveur et j'ai également
fait des concours
autour de la race bazadaise.
-On regarde une photo
ensemble de cette fête
des Boeufs gras de Bazas.
-Les boeufs gras de Bazas.
-D'accord.
-La bazadaise est
une race purement girondine
et voilà, j'ai été
un petit peu identifié
dans le milieu
de l'élevage au travers
de la race bazadaise.
J'ai eu le plaisir
de faire des concours
et de les gagner,
ce qui m'a permis
de faire du circuit court
et d'avoir une certaine renommée
autour de la viande de qualité.
-Cette sauce bordelaise ?
-Ca, c'est du faux-filet.
-Soyez indulgent, nous,
on le fait réchauffer,
c'est pas un restaurant,
et cette sauce bordelaise
est une sauce au vin ?
Du vin de chez vous.
-Vin et échalote.
Avec du fond de veau.
-Il faut mettre un bon vin ?
-Non, on peut mettre un vin de base,
c'est pas un problème. Le bon vin,
on le garde pour le boire. L'idée,
c'est de le cuire, d'essayer
de concentrer les arômes,
de les mélanger avec l'échalote
qui est assez relevée,
assez atypique. Et voilà,
on fait couler ça,
on nappe la viande.
-Avec cette sauce un peu
épaisse d'ailleurs.
-La typicité
de la consommation à Bordeaux,
c'est des viandes épaisses.
L'entrecôte,
c'est du 5, 6 cm, qu'on fait revenir
sur les sarments de vigne.
-C'est ça en fait qui fait
le goût de la viande.
-C'est également
le plat préféré des chasseurs
qui chassent la palombe
et quasiment tous les jours
dans les palombières,
dans le Sud-Ouest,
on mange également
l'entrecôte de boeuf de Bazas.
-C'est plus gras
que le faux-filet, l'entrecôte ?
-Oui, mais l'entrecôte,
le faux-filet, la basse côte,
tout ça, c'est pris
sur le dos de l'animal,
le long de la colonne vertébrale.
Vous avez d'abord
au plus près du collier, vous avez
les basses côtes, c'est un peu
plus ferme. Ca dépend des animaux.
Ensuite, vous avez l'entrecôte,
qui est assez grasse, elle peut être
persillée,
a des grands morceaux de nerfs
pour séparer les parties
malgré tout de l'entrecôte,
et ensuite,
vous avez le faux-filet qui
est un peu moins gras.
Et ensuite, vous avez le rumsteck,
qui est encore moins gras et qui est
avec une fibre plus serrée.
Il y en a pour tous les goûts,
et sachant qu'à Bordeaux,
on mange plutôt la viande
bleue à saignante pour garder
toute sa saveur.
-Bleue ?
-Tout son jus.
-3 choses à savoir, alors,
Jean-Pierre effectivement
pour réussir cette cuisson.
-Je m'adresse
à tous ceux qui cuisinent
de la viande chez eux.
Le plus simple,
c'est de cuire à la poêle.
L'assaisonner
avec du sel et du poivre,
préchauffer bien la poêle
avec huile ou beurre.
Pour la cuisson, comme l'a dit
M. le Député, juste saisie
pour un faux-filet bleu, 3 minutes
de chaque côté pour une pièce
un peu saignante et plus,
mais c'est souvent du gâchis,
pour une viande à point.
Laissez la viande reposer dans du
papier aluminium avant de déguster,
ça permet de faire un peu
évacuer le sang.
Au barbecue, vous avez
le choix, grillée ou marinée.
Je sais pas si vous aimez
la viande marinée.
Il y a toutes sortes de marinades.
Il faut préparer son grill
sur ce barbecue
en brossant à l'huile.
Et on fait un clic-clac,
2 à 3 minutes.
Enfin, cette viande tendre,
elle adore aussi
le four, être rôtie.
Alors, glissez-la au four.
Vous la saisissez d'abord
avant de la glisser
sur la poêle, un aller-retour,
et ensuite, 210, ça,
c'est 15 minutes
et si vous le voulez
un peu plus cuit,
c'est 12-15 minutes
et puis, vous baissez la température
entre 52 et 54, si vous rêvez
de déguster un rôti rosé.
C'est très bon aussi,
vous êtes d'accord avec moi ?
-Absolument d'accord.
Juste une chose à rajouter
par rapport
aux différentes cuissons,
la viande, on ne la cuit pas
dès la sortie du frigo,
on la laisse reposer 2 à 3 heures,
notamment quand on a des morceaux...
-J'ai lu
un quart d'heure.
-Ca dépend comment
est réglé votre frigo.
Si c'est un frigo de cuisine
classique, il est peut-être
à 6, 7 degrés, vous pouvez
vous contenter de ça, mais
si la viande est
entre 0 et 3 degrés,
laissez-lui le temps
de prendre la chaleur ambiante
de la cuisine, de la pièce,
elle n'en sera que meilleure.
-Alors, vous, vous avez
été éleveur, restaurateur,
mais ça veut pas dire cuisinier.
Est-ce que vous aimez
être en cuisine ? Savez-vous
cuisiner ? J'imagine la viande,
vous devez avoir
plein de recettes à nous raconter.
-Alors, en l'occurrence,
je ne suis pas
cuisinier de formation,
je n'ai pas de formation
technique en la matière.
J'ai fait tous les postes
dans mon établissement.
Mais en l'occurrence,
le poste que j'ai fait, on va dire,
le plus longtemps,
c'est celui de cuire
la viande à la plancha.
Donc c'est pas une cuisine très...
-C'est assez facile.
-C'est assez facile,
mais il faut quand même le faire
correctement, vous avez ceux qui
qui veulent bien cuit,
ceux qui veulent à point...
-Les pointilleux.
-Il s'appelait
La pièce de boeuf.
-Oui.
-C'est ça,
on y dégustait de la viande.
-Il y a pas de secrets.
-Vos boeufs en plus.
-Et avec ma viande,
oui.
-Un circuit
très court.
-Oui.
Votre collègue a dit
de la fourche à la fourchette.
Ca n'a pas empêché malgré tout
un client, je me rappelle,
un dimanche,
qui se pointe,
il venait de jouer de la musique
et il arrive en disant : "Pascal,
je suis végétarien,
"tu ne pourrais pas nous faire
des burgers végétariens ?"
Je lui ai dit,
tu as regardé l'enseigne ?
Et puis, je me suis ravisé,
il faut pas être caractériel,
il faut pas le prendre mal.
Je vais m'efforcer de lui faire
un hamburger végétarien.
C'était en été,
on a aussi beaucoup de légumes
dans le Sud-Ouest,
on a cette chance,
il y a des tomates,
en tous genres. En prenant
des bonnes tomates coeur de boeuf
où il y a assez peu
de pépins, beaucoup de chair, vous
la faites elle aussi, cette tomate,
juste snackée sur la plancha,
quelques herbes pour donner du goût,
de l'ail, vous mettez un oeuf,
car les végétariens mangent
également de l'oeuf et vous pouvez
arriver à faire
des magnifiques burgers.
Le gars est revenu, en disant,
c'est le meilleur burger végétarien
que j'aie mangé de ma vie.
-C'était
une réussite.
-C'est un exploit.
-Oui. Il faut rester ouvert
et j'aimerais que ceux qui sont
végétariens soient aussi ouverts
sur ceux qui mangent de la viande.
-Vous demandez de la réciprocité.
-J'ai beaucoup de respect
sur les uns ou sur les autres.
Ca m'est arrivé aussi
de débarrasser les assiettes
en salle,
et vous vous apercevez des fois
que le morceau de viande a
complètement disparu,
mais il reste des légumes,
et parfois beaucoup.
J'avais cette réflexion,
en disant, les protéines animales
ont de beaux restes.
-Ca vous a choqué cette radicalité
quand on a vu
des boucheries attaquées ?
-Oui.
Bien sûr, c'est choquant.
Sincèrement, s'en prendre aux biens,
s'en prendre aux personnes,
sous prétexte qu'ils ont
une orientation culinaire,
qu'ils continuent
à véhiculer une tradition bouchère,
c'est des métiers difficiles,
extrêmement nobles.
Mon père était boucher de métier.
Donc je connais également ça.
C'est jamais agréable quand
vous arrivez dans votre entreprise
et que vous voyez qu'on a sali
votre outil de travail
pour dénoncer ce que vous faites,
alors que ce que vous faites
est légal. C'est très désagréable.
Je comprends la colère des gens
quand ils sont victimes
de ces menaces-là,
qui sont véhiculées au coeur
de la nuit, dans l'anonymat,
sous des masques, alors qu'eux
travaillent de façon ouverte,
généreuse et à visage découvert.
-Vous avez vu que
la dernière boucherie chevaline
a fermé. Vous trouvez
que c'est une bonne chose ?
-Le cheval a une connotation
un petit peu particulière.
J'ai mangé de la viande de cheval
2, 3 fois peut-être dans ma vie,
je préfère la viande de boeuf,
qui est beaucoup plus grasse,
beaucoup plus goûteuse.
Il y a une proximité
effectivement affective
avec les chevaux.
-Que vous n'avez pas, vous,
avec vos boeufs ?
-Pas de la même façon.
On les monte pas.
-Non, parce que vous aimez
forcément vos bêtes.
-On peut pas faire
dans la sensiblerie.
C'est moi qui amenais mes animaux
à l'abattoir avec mon tracteur
et ma bétaillère. Je préférais,
parce qu'on se cache pas derrière
quelqu'un pour aller
accomplir un acte qui est pas
un acte très, très rigolo finalement
que de tuer un animal
pour le manger.
Mais depuis tout gosse, j'ai vécu
sur une ferme, le mercredi,
on tuait le lapin, on tuait
le poulet qu'on allait manger
au dîner, au déjeuner
ou au dîner.
Bah, je sais ça, on l'intègre,
on va pas en faire
une sensiblerie pour autant.
-Les temps changent,
les gens ne veulent plus
qu'on tue les animaux
pour se nourrir.
Une certaine partie
de la population.
-Beaucoup, effectivement,
on le voit,
mais j'ai l'impression
qu'il y a encore pas mal de gens
qui mangent de la viande,
au point qu'on doit importer
des viandes qu'on ne produit pas
en France, parce qu'on a tellement
jeté le discrédit
sur nos agriculteurs
que certains se découragent.
On décapitalise beaucoup
du cheptel français,
c'est dramatique. Je voudrais
réinsister sur ce que j'ai dit,
toutes les externalités positives
qu'apporte l'élevage à la France
et à ses paysages, mais également
à la gestion de la ressource en eau.
Vous savez,
toutes ces zones du Massif central
qui sont en zone herbagère,
qui servent
de filtre à l'eau,
qui servent de réserve
à l'eau du fait de la présence
d'un taux de matière organique
très élevé dans les sols herbagés
qui permet de stocker de l'eau.
C'est extrêmement important.
-On va voir si vous êtes incollable.
Le Quiz.
-En tant que chantre
d'une viande de qualité,
vous ne pouvez
que détester le fameux SPAM,
ce cousin du corned-beef.
Sauriez-vous nous dire
si ces affirmations au sujet du SPAM
sont vraies ou fausses ?
Le SPAM est né en 1937 pour offrir
une conserve rassasiante
et très bon marché
pendant la grande crise.
-Oui.
-Vrai, voilà, exactement.
Comme son cousin le corned-beef,
le SPAM est
de la viande de boeuf
cuite 3h dans une boîte
en métal.
-Je pense qu'il y a
d'autres viandes que le boeuf.
-Exactement. C'est pas du boeuf,
c'est de l'épaule de porc.
Bravo. 2 sur 2.
Pendant la Seconde Guerre mondiale,
les GI américains,
dégoûtés
par cette ration quotidienne,
le surnomment
"le jambon de singe mort".
-Oui.
-Non. Ils l'appellent "le jambon
"recalé à l'examen médical".
-C'est à peu près pareil.
-Le singe mort est
une de mes trouvailles.
Son succès a continué
après la guerre.
En 2007, dernier chiffre connu,
s'étaient vendues dans le monde
1 milliard de boîtes de SPAM.
-Faux.
-Vous diriez plus ou moins ?
-Je dirais moins.
-Non, 7 milliards !
C'est peut-être pas bon,
mais il y en a un paquet
qui en mange.
-Des gens en mangent.
-Et quand on a
un mail pourri,
on l'appelle le spam.
-En effet, dans les boîtes mail.
-On garde notre faux-filet.
-Oui ! Outre un gros consommateur
de viande,
que désigne aussi le mot viandard ?
Un cheval difforme ? Oui ou non.
-Non. Non.
-Oui !
Le mot viandard,
c'est aussi un cheval difforme.
Un chasseur compulsif ?
-Non.
-Oui !
Si, aussi.
-Ah oui, pardon. OK.
-C'est aussi un viandard.
Un homme qui ne réussit rien,
un loser ? Est-ce que
le mot viandard correspond
à cette définition ?
-Pas dans mon esprit,
non.
-Non, effectivement.
-Une grille
pour faire cuire la viande ?
-Non.
-Non plus.
-2 sur 4.
Très bien.
-50 % de réussite.
Alors,
avec une bonne viande, on boit
un bon vin.
-Oui.
Si possible.
-Et donc, on a
choisi, enfin,
vous avez choisi, un bordeaux,
un bordeaux supérieur.
C'est le château Franc Couplet.
On est sur un millésime 2016.
Evidemment, c'est un vin rouge
avec un cépage à 65 %
merlot, assez typique de ce
bordelais que vous connaissez bien.
Pourquoi l'avoir choisi ?
-Alors, il se trouve
que j'ai été, comme je vous l'ai
dit, conseiller agricole
avant d'être moi-même agriculteur.
Et j'ai eu l'occasion d'accompagner
des jeunes qui voulaient se diriger
vers la viticulture.
En l'occurrence...
J'en ai installé,
enfin, j'ai accompagné
pas mal de projets d'installation,
il fallait en choisir un,
c'était pas simple.
J'ai pris celui que je connaissais
depuis le plus longtemps,
c'est le château d'un ami,
qui s'appelle Eric Meynaud,
qui est installé
à Landerrouat, qui est
tout à fait à l'est
de mon territoire, à l'est
de L'Entre-deux-Mers
et de ma circonscription.
C'est quelqu'un
que je connais depuis 1987.
Moi, j'avais 20 ans,
lui en avait 15.
Et quelques années après,
après avoir fait
des études en lycée agricole
de viticulture-oenologie,
il a décidé
de s'installer. Son père avait déjà
une exploitation,
mais qui portait le raisin
en cave coopérative, une très belle
cave coopérative et lui, à partir
de 1995, s'est installé également,
mais a voulu en 1998
faire le virage
et lui-même vinifier.
-On sent que ça passe en barrique.
-Tout à fait. Petit à petit,
il a agrandi son exploitation
avec son épouse, qui l'a rejoint,
avec ses enfants,
qui sont pas encore en âge
de s'installer, mais qui ont
contribué en l'occurrence
à la création de cette cuvée.
C'est les 1ers, c'est les enfants
qui ont mis ce vin
en barrique en premier
sur la 1re année où ils ont décidé
de faire cette cuvée.
Et c'est vraiment
un bordeaux supérieur qui est digne
d'un grand vin de bordeaux.
Il y a beaucoup de variabilité
qualitative,
mais je voulais montrer
au travers de ce château,
comme quoi des gens qui sont
installés à titre individuel
ont fait de gros investissements,
de gros efforts
en termes de vinification,
se sont fait accompagner
par des oenologues, ont embrassé
des techniques et des technologies
modernes, le microbullage,
et ont passé leur vin
en barrique et font des vins
qui sont remarquables
dans une appellation
assez modeste
qu'est l'appellation...
-Pas forcément la plus vendeuse
à côté de Saint-Emilion, Pomerol.
-Qui ne bénéficie pas de ce renom,
mais on peut faire des choses
très bien. Grand plaisir
de vous le faire découvrir.
-C'est un très bon accord
avec la viande.
-J'ai une question, Brigitte.
Quand on a une viande
avec une sauce au vin et qu'on doit
rajouter du vin, il y a
des précautions à prendre ?
Les 2 vins doivent-ils s'accorder ?
On peut boire du vin blanc ?
-Du vin blanc,
j'aurais pas préconisé
pour cette sauce bordelaise.
Mais en l'occurrence,
le vin qui est dans la sauce
est déjà très cuit.
Donc, de toute façon,
il a perdu ce côté alcooleux.
Je crois qu'un vin rouge
est le meilleur accord possible
et un vin de bordeaux,
c'est une valeur très, très sûre.
Avec 65 % merlot, 25 %
cabernet sauvignon,
10 % cabernet franc,
qui apporte un peu de fraîcheur.
-C'est ça.
-C'est un bon choix.
-Merci.
-Félicitations.
-Ca fera plaisir
au propriétaire.
-C'est souvent autour
de la table que se racontent
les meilleures histoires,
que se nouent parfois
des deals politiques.
La brève de comptoir.
Pascal Lavergne,
on vous a demandé de réfléchir
à une anecdote politique
autour d'un repas. Y a-t-il
une histoire que vous pouvez
nous raconter ?
-Une anecdote politique
autour d'un repas, oui.
L'anecdote politique qui a
sans doute le plus marqué ma vie
politique, c'est quand
un 17 ou un 18 octobre,
j'étais sur mon tracteur le matin
en train de soigner mes vaches,
j'étais déjà maire
de mon village, Monségur,
et je reçois un coup de fil,
"Allô, c'est Pierre-Gaël Bessière,
"du pôle politique
et parlementaire de l'Elysée."
"Oui, bonjour."
"C'est M. Lavergne." Il avait l'air
surpris. Il me dit :
"Vous savez qu'on vient
"de nommer Mme Christelle
Dubos au gouvernement ?"
Je lui dis :
"Non, vous me l'apprenez".
C'est à ce moment-là, comme j'étais
suppléant de Christelle Dubos,
que j'apprends
que je deviens député.
Il y a une expression,
"tomber de l'armoire",
moi, du tracteur.
-Vous avez arrêté le tracteur.
-Oui, oui. Il a fallu continuer
à soigner les vaches,
mais dès ce moment-là, en fait,
tout un tas de coups de fil,
de journalistes, d'amis
qui regardaient les journaux
télévisés ou écoutaient
la radio, apprenaient la nouvelle
en même temps que moi,
le 1er concerné,
mais qui débarquait.
-Vous étiez heureux
votre aventure à l'Assemblée ?
-Evidemment, mais c'était pas
forcément prévu à ce moment-là.
-Vous ne pensiez
jamais accéder
à l'Assemblée nationale ?
-Oui.
Dans ces nouveaux députés de 2017,
dont était Christelle Dubos,
on savait pas qui était prédestiné
à rentrer au gouvernement.
Et quand je me suis engagé
comme suppléant auprès d'elle,
ni elle ni moi n'avions imaginé
que ça puisse arriver.
Donc moi, j'étais là au cas où,
mais quand on a 42 ans, l'âge
de Christelle Dubos,
j'avais pas envie qu'elle meure
et elle non plus,
elle est rentrée au gouvernement,
la 1re alternative pour que
je siège.
C'est pourquoi je suis venu ici
sur le mandat précédent
pendant 20 mois.
-Vous vous êtes demandé
comment faire le travail aux champs
et le travail à l'Assemblée ?
-Oui, c'est quelque chose
qui vous traverse l'esprit.
Il y a pas de doute. La 1re chose
qui m'a traversé l'esprit,
c'est qu'est-ce que je vais faire
de mes 2 chiennes ? Une labrador
et sa fille, qui est croisée.
La labrador est plus là,
elle est décédée
cette année,
mais je me suis posé la question,
parce que je suis célibataire,
je vivais tout seul sur ma ferme,
j'étais pas coupé du monde,
avec le restaurant,
l'activité de maire,
mais je me suis dit
qui pour s'occuper de mes chiennes ?
Pour les vaches,
c'était pas un souci.
Je pouvais embaucher
quelqu'un.
-Ils gardent pas aussi les chiens ?
-C'est-à-dire que les vaches,
vous les soignez le matin,
vous les surveillez 1 ou 2 fois
par jour en cas de vêlage,
les chiennes ont besoin d'affection,
elles étaient
tout le temps avec moi à la ferme,
ça a été ma 1re préoccupation. C'est
quand même compliqué à gérer d'être
à la fois parlementaire,
d'avoir une ferme et un restaurant.
Il m'est arrivé
d'avoir des coups de fil à 9h30
du soir, alors que la nuit tombe,
pour me dire, "Pascal, tes vaches
sont sur la route à tel endroit."
Vous avez intérêt à avoir
des bons copains pas loin,
qui se mobilisent
pour faire rentrer les vaches.
-Les chiens, ils sont allés où ?
-Ils sont restés à la maison.
J'ai fait une chatière pour chiens,
et puis, petit à petit,
elles se sont habituées
à vivre avec un peu plus d'autonomie
et du plaisir
à me retrouver le mercredi soir,
le jeudi soir
ou le vendredi soir.
-Ca vous fera plaisir ou pas,
mais les Français
se rapprochent de la terre.
Pour certains, ça passe
par le Wwoofing et ça permet
de découvrir d'autres cuisines.
Le dessous des plats.
-Ah, le Wwoofing !
Derrière cet anglicisme se cache
une pratique en plein essor, un
échange sans contrepartie monétaire,
les hôtes des exploitations
agricoles, souvent familiales,
toujours bio,
proposent le gîte et le couvert
contre une aide dans les champs,
auprès des bêtes
ou pour toute tâche agricole,
un reportage bucolique d'Hélène
Bonduelle et de Philippe Lecros.
-Manu est
en reconversion professionnelle.
Elle veut se lancer
dans le maraîchage.
-On va commencer avec les tomates,
pommes de terre et framboises
et quelques poireaux aussi,
toi, tu kiffes les poireaux.
-Moi, j'aime tout, moi.
-Dans la microferme de Kate,
elle est venue s'enrichir
de nouvelles techniques agricoles.
-J'aime bien l'idée d'expérimenter,
voir si, dans le quotidien,
toutes les tâches, leur diversité,
qu'on peut faire me plaisent
et si j'ai envie de le faire
de manière plus durable.
Comment faire ses semis,
gérer son compost, il y a énormément
de choses qu'on apprend
et c'est vraiment chouette.
-Manu est une Wwoofeuse,
le principe est simple,
elle offre
quelques heures de travail
à Kate, agricultrice bio,
partage les travaux de la ferme,
mais pas seulement.
-L'idée, avec le Wwoofing,
c'est que ça devient pas un salarié.
Pour moi, le but,
c'était qu'ils vivaient avec nous,
ils partageaient tous nos repas,
les bons moments de la vie,
les mauvais moments.
-Comme elle, ce sont souvent
des jeunes de 18 à 35 ans,
plutôt urbains, qui s'essaient
à ces échanges.
Plus de 2500 fermes, toutes bio,
sélectionnées par l'association
WWOOF France.
-On a 2000 Wwoofeurs,
qui sont devenus
paysans et paysannes et qui ont vu,
au-delà du texte,
au-delà des discours,
ce qui fonctionne
et ce qui fonctionne pas
en termes de modèle agricole.
C'est aussi une manière
de venir se confronter au terrain
et de parler
de modèle économique aussi.
C'est pas juste
faire pousser, c'est aussi
comment vendre sa production.
En anglais
-That's the famous chutney.
-Oh, great !
-Une forme de reconnexion
à la terre,
à son alimentation aussi.
-Un des principes, c'est
qu'on crée la belle nourriture,
donc on va prendre
le temps de faire des expériences,
de faire des beaux plats,
de profiter
de les "belles" nutriments,
aliments que l'on produit.
-Il y a une vraie notion
de partage aussi autour du repas
et les discussions qui vont avec,
c'est vraiment riche.
Et les découvertes aussi culinaires.
-Oui,
on avait des Wwoofeurs
japonais qui ont créé
des plats magnifiques.
Donc oui, c'est vraiment
une découverte dans les deux sens.
-Cette reconnexion
à la terre, ça doit
vous faire plaisir ou vous jugez
que c'est un peu gadget
et ça vous agace ?
-Euh... Gagdet, oui, enfin,
j'ai qualifié ça tout à l'heure
un petit peu, c'est du "boboïsme".
C'est très bien de vouloir
recoller à la nature,
mais aujourd'hui, enfin, c'est pas
la vie d'une vraie ferme...
-Si, ce sont des exploitations
familiales, pas des grandes...
-Je ne dis pas
que ce ne sont pas de vraies...
-Vous disiez que vous étiez
indulgent et tolérant.
-Pas de problème.
Je veux revenir
à un principe de réalité.
Ce n'est pas
avec des fermes comme ça,
qu'il faudrait multiplier
de façon très importante,
qu'on permet d'arriver
à la souveraineté alimentaire.
Aujourd'hui, avec un modèle
productiviste, mais respectueux
de l'environnement, respectueux
de la biodiversité
et de plus en plus,
on a du mal à être autonome
en France en termes
de production alimentaire.
Sincèrement, personne ne me fera
croire que c'est ce modèle-là
qu'il faut multiplier demain
sur le territoire
pour permettre
d'arriver
à cette souveraineté alimentaire
que l'on a perdue en France.
-Néanmoins, les 2 modèles
sont-ils complémentaires ?
-Tout à fait. Il faut effectivement
faire coexister ces 2 modèles,
tout simplement
parce qu'on le voit bien
avec l'inflation
qui est réapparue dans notre pays
depuis la guerre en Ukraine,
que les Français consacrent
une certaine part de leurs revenus
et de leur budget à l'alimentation.
Et on voit bien
que, finalement, les Français
se sont... le consommateur
s'est détourné des produits bio,
qui sont souvent plus chers,
parce qu'ils requièrent
beaucoup plus de main-d'oeuvre,
avec moins de rendement
à l'hectare ou au mètre carré
quand il s'agit
de fruits et légumes,
et les gens se sont détournés du bio
pour pouvoir continuer à manger
à leur faim
et équilibrer leur budget,
parce qu'ils ont été obligés
de consacrer plus de leurs revenus
au logement, plus de leurs revenus
à l'énergie et sans doute
beaucoup trop de leurs revenus
à ce que j'ai donné tout à l'heure,
c'est-à-dire mon smartphone.
A un moment donné,
il faut aussi assumer ça.
Le fait que, depuis 30 ou 40 ans,
on diminue la part
de nos revenus, la part
de l'alimentation,
qu'on consacre à notre alimentation,
par rapport à nos revenus.
N'allons pas me faire croire
que c'est en n'ayant
que des produits
plus chers qu'on va pouvoir
répondre à cette exigence.
-Le modèle productiviste.
-Je défends un modèle
qui soit à la fois productiviste,
respectueux de l'environnement,
et qui va toujours vers...
et qui tire vers le haut
le respect de la biodiversité,
l'utilisation moindre
des phytosanitaires.
Tout ça, c'est en route,
les agriculteurs,
comme je l'ai dit en introduction,
ils ont compris
ce message que leur envoie
la société,
que leur envoient les citoyens,
mais il y a
une forme de schizophrénie
entre le Français citoyen
et le Français consommateur.
Le Français citoyen a des exigences
en termes de normes de production,
en termes de qualité de production,
de respect de l'environnement.
Et consommateur, il veut un prix bas
et regarde pas d'où ça vient.
On impose des normes
à nos producteurs
qui conduisent à ce que ça renchérit
le coût de l'alimentation
produite en France.
Le consommateur s'en détourne
et achète des produits moins chers
qui viennent de l'étranger,
de continents extérieurs,
comme le Brésil,
où on déforeste entre 200 000
et 400 000 hectares par an.
Essayons de remettre les choses
à l'endroit. Si aujourd'hui
dans nos circonscriptions,
nous avons des agriculteurs
qui retournent les panneaux...
-Justement...
-C'est sans doute qu'il y a
une raison.
-Revenons
au Wwoofing, vous avez parlé
des petites exploitations bio.
Vous dites, c'est pas gérable...
-J'ai pas dit ça.
-Ca nous permettra pas d'obtenir
la souveraineté.
Ce qui est intéressant aussi,
ce sont ces jeunes
qui vont, qui font
des reconversions,
qui vont vers la terre,
qui ont envie de la travailler
différemment,
avec pratiques ancestrales.
Ca devrait vous plaire.
-Vous n'avez pas l'air très adepte.
-Ca me plaît...
-Vous êtes pas
enthousiaste.
-On n'empêche pas les gens
de faire ce qu'ils veulent.
-Vous qui êtes près de la nature,
vous devriez vous réjouir.
-On est d'accord, mais la mission
première de l'agriculture,
c'est de nourrir les gens.
-Oui.
-En 1963...
-Ca peut cohabiter.
-Quand les lois d'orientation
sur l'agriculture
ont été faites, c'était
de dire aux agriculteurs, produisez,
de façon suffisante et massive,
pour qu'on puisse nourrir
à bas coûts, à bas prix,
la population. L'agriculture a
répondu à cette mission. Il faut
qu'elle continue.
Sinon nous dépendrons
de modèles agricoles que
nous ne maîtrisons pas,
qui sont sur d'autres continents
et qui bien souvent seront
gérés par des dictatures
plutôt que par des démocraties
comme la France.
-Est-ce que ce genre d'initiatives
peut rapprocher
l'urbain du rural, l'urbain
de l'agriculteur ?
-Elle le rapproche
sans tenir compte
de ce principe de réalité
qu'il faut être capable
de produire des carottes
à un certain prix
pour qu'elles soient
compétitives, du poulet...
-Ca peut permettre
de comprendre vos contraintes.
-Il faut comprendre l'ensemble
des contraintes.
Et c'est bien la vocation de la loi
d'orientation agricole
que de rouvrir
les exploitations agricoles,
mais je veux qu'on les rouvre,
mais les vraies exploitations,
celles qui
remplissent les rayons
des supermarchés.
-C'est l'agriculture intensive ?
-Oui, mais agriculture intensive,
agriculture conventionnelle,
c'est pas un gros mot. Aujourd'hui,
c'est répondre
à une demande du marché qui est de
produire des carottes, des pommes,
de la viande de poulet,
de la viande de boeuf,
à un certain prix.
Si on ne sait pas dans un marché
mondialisé produire
à ces conditions-là,
finalement, nous serons sous le coup
de dictatures, comme nous aurions
pu l'être concernant l'énergie.
Et demain, je ne veux pas
que l'alimentation
des Françaises et des Français
dépende de dictateurs
qui leur feront manger
ce qu'ils veulent.
-Il y a une réalité
que vous ne voulez pas voir,
c'est que ces jeunes gens,
cette jeune génération n'a pas
la même idée
de la souveraineté alimentaire,
de la production agricole.
Est-ce que vous pensez quand même
que vous pouvez
être d'accord
avec ces nouvelles techniques,
cette nouvelle appréhension ?
Moins de viande,
parce que ces nouveaux
agriculteurs veulent traiter
la terre différemment
de la façon
dont elle a été traitée
par leurs aînés,
ils sont en rupture avec vous.
-Ce qu'ils veulent, c'est
bien, je les empêcherai pas,
mais ils vont vite se rendre compte
que la société va
leur demander de produire
ce qu'ils ont envie de manger.
Et le prix auquel ils ont envie
de manger et le budget
qu'ils veulent y consacrer.
Laissons les choses
se développer les unes
à côté des autres,
ne privilégions pas
un modèle sur l'autre.
Mais ne condamnons pas, de grâce,
ne condamnons pas
le modèle qui,
depuis les années 60,
permet de vivre et a permis
de consacrer moins
pour son alimentation par rapport
à l'ensemble de ses revenus
et de pouvoir bénéficier
d'une part plus importante
pour ses loisirs, son habitation,
pour sa qualité de vie
et pour sa santé.
Ne cassons pas
ce modèle-là,
parce qu'il est risqué, je veux
qu'on prenne conscience
de ce risque,
de devoir demain dépendre
des autres,
dépendre d'autres continents,
d'autres pouvoirs politiques
pour manger à sa faim.
-Est-ce que, pour avoir
cette souveraineté,
il faut du glyphosate ?
Le glyphosate vient d'être reconduit
pour 10 ans dans l'Union Européenne.
Classé cancérigène probable
par le Centre international
de Recherche sur le Cancer.
ce choix suscite la controverse.
On en parle et on met
les pieds dans le plat.
Le glyphosate a été réduit
de plus 25 %
depuis l'arrivée d'Emmanuel Macron,
qui en a fait un de ses combats.
La France souhaite en sortir
et cherche des alternatives.
Si certains parviennent
à s'en passer,
ce n'est pas le cas
de toutes les exploitations.
Reportage d'Ariane Maurisson
et d'Augustin Arnal.
-A l'approche des semis,
Sébastien Berger contrôle
l'état de son champ.
Il y a quelques jours,
il a désherbé sa parcelle
en utilisant un produit chimique,
du glyphosate.
-Tous les 15 jours, 3 semaines,
on a une plante qui dessèche,
et on obtient ce genre de choses,
une plante qui n'a plus
de chlorophylle.
-Depuis 3 ans,
cet agriculteur a divisé
par 2 sa consommation
de glyphosate
grâce au désherbage mécanique.
Un complément efficace,
mais impossible selon lui
de se priver totalement
de l'herbicide.
-On a des plantes résistantes,
invasives,
et ces plantes-là,
à part le glyphosate,
aujourd'hui, j'ai rien.
-Il répand un litre d'herbicide
dilué par hectare
de culture.
-Là, j'ai, de mon côté droit,
la fameuse molécule
du glyphosate.
-Malgré la dangerosité,
il continue d'utiliser la molécule
pour assurer ses récoltes,
faute d'alternative efficace.
-C'est pas parce qu'on l'a employé
qu'on l'emploiera demain.
La preuve en est :
nos pratiques vont
vers des pratiques
plus vertueuses.
Chez moi, on en consommait
800 litres
il y a quelques années.
Aujourd'hui,
j'en suis rendu à 400.
Demain, ça ira peut-être
en diminuant.
-A quelques kilomètres de là,
pendant 12 ans,
Damien a lui aussi pulvérisé
du glyphosate.
En 2016, il a renoncé
au produit chimique
et s'est converti
à l'agriculture biologique.
Il ne compte que sur des outils
mécaniques pour désherber.
-Les pousses de tournesol
sont arrachées,
et les quelques mauvaises herbes
qui sont présentes dans le champ
sont aussi arrachées.
-Un procédé plus long
et plus coûteux
qu'il amortit avec un prix de vente
plus élevé.
L'absence de recours au glyphosate
est avant tout
un moyen de protéger
l'environnement.
-Aujourd'hui, il y a des études
qui le montre : ça coûte moins cher
d'aider l'agriculteur
que de dépolluer l'eau.
-Le glyphosate demeure l'herbicide
le plus utilisé en France.
En 2021, près de 7800 tonnes
ont été vendus
sur le territoire national,
un chiffre en légère baisse
ces dernières années.
-Vous avez exploité de la vigne.
Est-ce que vous utilisiez
du glyphosate ou non ?
-J'ai utilisé du glyphosate.
C'est compliqué,
dans la vigne,
de se passer du glyphosate.
-C'est compliqué ?
-Tout du moins sous le rang.
De plus en plus,
les viticulteurs s'en passent.
J'ai fait partie de ceux...
J'ai eu mes vignes en 1997,
de ceux qui n'ont pas travaillé
leurs vignes,
qui ont laissé enherber
l'inter-rang.
Déjà, c'est une orientation.
Néanmoins,
il y a la nécessité de désherber
sous le rang.
Aujourd'hui, du matériel
permet de tondre sous le rang,
de cavaillonner, de décavaillonner,
de travailler le sol.
Ca n'a pas que
des effets positifs,
mais on peut s'en passer.
Pas toujours.
Mais je peux vous assurer
que là aussi,
le monde agricole a beaucoup diminué
l'utilisation
du glyphosate.
Pour autant, il y a,
à mon sens, la nécessité
de le maintenir pour pouvoir
détruire
des plantes qui prolifèrent.
On n'a pas d'autre solution.
-Vous pensez
que la Commission européenne a pris
une bonne décision ?
-Je pense que la Commission
européenne...
-10 ans, sans restriction.
-Je pense que la Commission a fait
une erreur politique.
Ca remet, en fait, une couche
de volonté de combattre
le glyphosate
alors qu'il a son utilisé
pour l'agriculture.
La position française, qui était
intermédiaire, de donner
une durée supplémentaire de 5 ans
pour laisser le temps
de trouver des alternatives.
Il y a des alternatives.
Elles nécessitent
des investissements
des agriculteurs.
Pour investir, il faut également
dégager des marges,
dégager des résultats,
avoir des technologies
qui soient vraiment avérées.
On a des marges de progrès
grâce à la recherche.
-Financièrement,
vous n'auriez pas pu le faire ?
-Je suis hors course, maintenant,
par rapport aux vignes.
C'est pas tellement là
qu'est le problème,
c'est surtout
dans les grandes cultures.
On tolère plus facile
dans les vignes
d'avoir de l'herbe sous les pieds,
déjà parce que le climat a
un peu évolué
aussi, même si
ça laisse des supports
pour pouvoir véhiculer
des spores de mildiou
jusque sur les feuilles.
C'est par ricochet
avec les gouttes d'eau
que le mildiou remonte
sur le feuillage.
-On ne vaporise pas le glyphosate
sur la vigne.
-Les gouttes d'eau,
c'est des gouttes de pluie
qui véhiculent le mildiou.
Le glyphosate, en viticulture,
on l'utilise à des doses faibles,
uniquement sous le rang,
alors qu'on pouvait l'utiliser
à une époque sur la totalité
de la surface.
Sincèrement, en viticulture,
c'est pas un problème.
Dans les grandes cultures,
on voit qu'il y a des méthodes
qui sont plutôt
positives, comme les cultures
de conservation,
qui consistent à faire une rotation
des cultures
avec plusieurs plans,
mais qui...
Empêchent, qui évitent
de travailler le sol
en supprimant la technique
de labour, qui est néfaste
pour les matières organiques,
pour plein de choses,
la minéralisation, également,
des...
Des éléments qui proviennent du sol
et qui proviennent du sous-sol.
On met en place ces cultures
en laissant pousser, l'hiver,
des plantes,
et on les détruit
avec une petite dose de glyphosate
de 1 à 1,5 litre par hectare.
C'est extrêmement faible.
Rendez-vous compte que nous avons
entre 20 000 et 30 000 tonnes
de terres par hectares,
de terres arables.
1 litre à 1,5 litre.
C'est pas comme...
-Donc à faible dose,
c'est pas cancérigène probable,
comme le dit le Centre...
-Mais le CIRC,
le Centre international
de Recherche,
dit que le glyphosate est
cancérigène probable
et je ne dis pas l'inverse.
En l'occurrence, c'est classé en A,
comme les charcuteries,
ou comme la viande rouge.
Est-ce qu'on interdit la charcuterie
et la viande rouge ?
C'est une question
d'exposition et de dose.
Ca fait 50 ans
que le glyphosate est utilisé.
J'écoutais Patrick Cohen
qui régissait dans un édito
par rapport à la réintroduction
du glyphosate.
Sincèrement, si, vraiment,
il y avait une toxicité très forte,
ça se saurait.
Je ne dis pas
qu'il n'y a pas des expositions
qui peuvent générer des cancers...
-La première fois,
il y a un jeune garçon,
Théo Grataloup,
qui a été reconnu victime
du glyphosate.
-Mais dans quelles conditions
d'exposition ?
C'est très difficile,
quand on prend des exemples...
-Des études disent
tout et le contraire.
Est-ce que cette décision européenne
ne va pas pénaliser
les agriculteurs français ?
La règle française est plus dure.
-Je crois, oui.
C'est ce que j'ai dit
tout à l'heure.
Ca n'aide pas l'agriculture
française et ça remet
le glyphosate
sur le devant de la scène
et ça rejette l'opprobre
sur le monde agricole,
alors que le monde agricole
a fait beaucoup d'efforts.
Nous aurions souhaité,
c'est la position
de la France,
du ministre de l'Agriculture :
"Alignons-nous
sur la position française,
"qui a permis de faire baisser
l'usage du glyphosate de 25 %",
notamment
parce que la SNCF n'utilise plus
de glyphosate,
les communes non plus
pour les cimetières
et les routes.
Réservons le glyphosate
dans des conditions modérées
pour l'agriculture,
là où on n'a pas le choix,
en attendant de trouver
des alternatives.
Je suis persuadé
que la recherche en trouvera.
-Avant 10 ans ?
-Pour donner
un petit coup de boost
à la recherche et aux fabricants
de matériel agricole,
tout en laissant le temps
aux agriculteurs
de pouvoir avoir
une capacité d'investissement
5 ans, c'était
une bonne limite.
Quitte à revoir après 5 ans.
10 ans d'un coup,
finalement, est-ce qu'on va faire
les efforts...
-Pour chercher des alternatives.
-5 ans,
c'était le bon timing.
J'étais aligné
sur la position française,
Ursula von der Leyen
a décidé autrement.
-Pour des raisons politiques.
-Il faut aussi montrer,
quand on est responsable politique,
que même si on considère
que comme produit,
il est pas aussi néfaste
que certains
ont voulu le dire,
qu'on fait un pas
en direction des populations
qui nous le demandent.
-Nous, on a une restriction
plus importante sur le glyphosate.
Ca crée une distorsion
de concurrence.
Est-ce qu'on va pas réutiliser
davantage de glyphosate
pendant 10 ans ?
-Les agriculteurs
sont des gens raisonnables
et intelligents.
Les efforts qu'ils ont faits,
les techniques
qu'ils ont mises en oeuvre
qui sont vertueuses,
ils continueront
et ils ne reviendront pas
en arrière.
Et la réglementation française
ne reviendra pas en arrière.
Je regrette
que nous soyons seuls,
mais je suis content
que ce glyphosate puisse continuer
à exister,
c'est dommage que ce ne soit pas
dans des conditions
un petit peu plus exigeantes
partout dans le monde
et en Europe.
Je préfère qu'on s'aligne
vers le mieux 10 ans
que vers le moins 10 ans.
-C'est une décision de l'Europe.
Des agriculteurs se plaignent
des normes européennes
qui entravent leur travail,
aujourd'hui,
et ils ont mis leur panneau
à l'envers.
-J'ai aussi le panneau de ma commune
qui est à l'envers, j'ai vu ça
sur Facebook. Bon...
-Vous dites stop
aux normes européennes ?
-J'étais à l'Assemblée aujourd'hui,
mais je l'ai vu.
-C'est pour dire quoi,
finalement ?
-C'est pour dénoncer, sans doute,
la surtransposition
qu'on a eu tendance à faire
beaucoup trop
pendant de longues années,
et pas forcément
avec les gouvernements
d'Emmanuel Macron.
Il aurait pu y avoir
une forme de tentation.
Je voudrais sincèrement
bien redire
l'utilité,
que ce soit le politique
et le politique seul
qui soit à la manoeuvre
pour les décisions.
C'est lui qui, après,
est en première ligne
pour prendre des coups
et pour justifier des décisions.
Parfois, elles sont prises,
on va dire,
par des administrations
qui ne sont pas exposées.
Il faut que le politique...
-Vous êtes solidaire
de ces panneaux retournés ?
-D'une certaine façon, oui.
Effectivement, je comprends
le ras-le-bol du monde paysan.
Je ne serais pas allé manifester
ou retourner des panneaux moi-même,
mais je le comprends
et je suis solidaire.
Ils ont envie d'une lisibilité
pour les 5 à 10 ans à venir.
Ils ne veulent plus
de surtransposition,
voir disparaître
des produits sans alternative,
et je ne peux que les comprendre,
d'autant que nous ne faisons pas
respecter
les clauses miroir de pays
comme le Brésil,
qui continue
à déforester 200 à 400 000 hectares
par an de forêt tropical
malgré le changement climatique,
et on voudrait dire
à nos agriculteurs :
"Plantez des haies, sinon,
vous dégradez le climat" ?
Il faut faire porter
les responsabilités
aux responsables.
-On passe au dessert
avec le péché mignon.
-Pascal Lavergne est déjà passé
au dessert.
Il nous a pas attendus.
-C'est vrai.
-La tarte au citron, il adore.
Une tarte au citron sans meringue,
c'était votre choix,
une tarte de saison
qui porte mal son nom
puisqu'il n'y a pas de fruit.
C'est un mélange assez riche
constitué d'oeuf, de sucre
et de jus de citron.
C'est une crème appelée
chez les Anglais
"lemon curd", donc c'est assez lourd
pour une tarte aux fruits.
Cette tarte est de saison,
les agrumes sont de saison en hiver,
mais vous avez tenu
à ce que cette tarte,
que vous adorez,
soit sans meringue.
La meringue tue le goût du citron ?
-Ce que je vais chercher
dans une tarte au citron,
ce que je cherche,
c'est le citron et l'acide.
A partir du moment
où on rajoute dessus
une meringue sucrée,
on va perdre, en fait,
cet équilibre qui tend vers l'acide,
et en fin de repas,
je préfère un dessert qui tend
sur l'acide
qu'un dessert qui tend
sur le sucre.
Et pourquoi cette tarte ?
-C'est sucré, comme tarte.
-Elle est sucrée,
mais en termes de goût,
c'est pour ça que je l'ai goûtée,
on a quand même bien l'acide
qui domine.
-C'est ça qui vous plaît.
Vous aimez moins le sucre.
-C'est ce côté
qui est un peu...
Qui énerve un peu les papilles,
qui énerve la langue.
-C'est la tarte au citron,
pas les tartes aux fruits ?
-Je peux,
mais j'ai choisi
la tarte au citron
parce que c'est un dessert
que j'avais dans mon restaurant.
On a commencé par certains desserts,
et il faut renouveler,
et comme j'aimais bien
la tarte au citron,
je me suis dit :
"Je vais me mettre à en faire."
-Vous savez la faire ?
-Oui, mais enfin,
pas de façon...
Extrêmement artisanale.
Dans un restaurant,
on a des obligations
de normes sanitaires.
Utiliser des oeufs qu'on casse,
c'est embêtant.
C'est relativement simple.
C'est 1 litre de jus de citron
qu'on mélange
avec de la crème à froid,
un mélange tout préparé
mais extrêmement stabilisé,
où il y a de la farine,
des oeufs pasteurisés,
mais par contre,
il a fallu que je trouve
le bon équilibre
entre ce que j'aimais,
faire ressortir l'acide,
et le fait
que ce mélange tout prêt
du commerce,
qui permet de travailler
en toute sécurité sanitaire,
était un peu sucré.
Ce que j'avais rajouté,
qui n'est peut-être pas là,
c'est de la crème chantilly
non sucrée, qui permet
d'alléger,
de donner ce côté
un peu gras. Ce qui peut être aussi
intéressant visuellement
pour rappeler le citron,
c'est d'avoir des tranches de citron
très fines...
-Des zestes de citron ?
-On peut mettre du zeste
de citron vert,
ça a un arôme sympathique.
Mais on peut,
sur le plan visuel,
mettre cette tranche
de citron,
qu'on fait soi-même confire
dans du sucre,
du sucre et de l'eau.
On la fait confire
et on la met sur le bord
pour rappeler le fruit.
-On finit avec une chanson
que vous avez choisie.
-On va garder ses larmes.
"A nos souvenirs",
Trois Cafés Gourmands
...
-Vous avez la larme à l'oeil.
-N'insistez pas !
-Qu'est-ce qu'elle évoque,
cette chanson ?
-Mon Limousin natal.
J'en dirai pas plus.
Tout est dans la chanson.
Je suis né dans le Limousin,
Là, c'est la Corrèze,
une partie
du Limousin.
Je suis né à Limoges,
mon père habite là-bas.
Je lui rends hommage.
-Merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation,
Pascal Lavergne.
Merci
pour ce déjeuner.
Merci à Chez Françoise,
qui nous a servi
ces bons petits plats.
On se retrouve la semaine prochaine
pour un autre numéro,
sur LCP.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
...